welcome back thank you for for
persisting for traversing space and time
from making it to this point we were
going to continue once again i am still
continuously erin and i am still
persistently Jerry yeah so for any of
you guys who have problems with object
permanence um get over yourselves get
over that [ __ ] eat your heart out uh
yeah that part to a rousing discussions
dank ass Brad bag just wank mass laser
tag this one gasps laser tag Frank a
stub we should do laser tag I'm done
laser tag since I was a lad let's go now
let's go now let's do an episode where
we laser tag you guys you guys listen to
more of us talking about [ __ ] and
we're gonna go play laser tag hi it's
interesting you know we're talking about
a lot of things that are very strong
ideas that just don't pan out for
whatever reason because we were we
recently at a trade show in the LA area
for the haunting poorer community yeah
or scare away spooky day yeah scare la
it's um it's a no-trade shop for just
everything in the horror community
mostly out like the the Corazon
specifically it's not specific it's it's
focused on building actual haunted
houses and things like that well yeah
and it seems like it's it's come into
its own that way and like I i remember
the first true then you go the second
year for the first year it seemed like
there were a lot of vendors and there
was a lot of like horror movie merch and
stuff like that and there was definitely
like a haunt presence but now it seems
like it's really come into its own in
terms of like on specific foods in the
different aspects of that you know there
are classes and crafts and their props
and then see makeup makeup in special
effects companies like showing Hawking
their wares of like hey you know have us
do the prosthetics for your your actors
in your haunt and things like that yeah
it does seem like it's distinct to find
itself from more like a fan convention
like days of the Dead and more
like a makeup specific convention like
monsterpalooza like you know it's it's
coming to its own as the haunt show
which I think yeah there was a big
pumpkin outside there is a big pumpkin
that was that was so hard to get clear
for photograph wanted a pumpkin pick a
pump pick but ya know what were you
going to say what was your well while we
were there at at Scare outlay I bumped
into someone we know who basically was
talking about alone oh Sh as any was
just saying like I'm getting tired of
their [ __ ] every every show they do is
always a little bit worse than their
last thing interesting I mean I don't
you've gone through more of their stuff
than i have so i don't know if that's a
similar a similar experience you've had
yeah oh I don't think so by like what I
these ones aren't they're not as good as
the first one I went to in necessarily
like they're not I don't have that same
like oh yeah [ __ ] hoes amazing but um
I still like what they're getting at and
it's like I want to I feel like this is
part of its a four step process yeah and
I kind of want to see how it ends up and
this one was you know it's like this one
was smaller um because it was for the
the show yeah at Sierra later was the
second half of the the fee alone the new
alone series and it took place teen like
the exhibition rooms in campus this back
stage II sort of zone yeah I mean it was
in a different part of the center more
like worst of my conference rooms and
stuff were and I get the sense that's
they gave them they said when I talked
to the creators after the last one I
said sort of um after the scavenger hunt
January they they sort of said they
asked us to do one of these last year at
Scare LA and they just sit like the
nature of what they do
is you know it's hard to put tons of
people through it's not like some of the
other fold-up mazes that you know worth
that are at that convention because
there are some other things but that was
their sort of featured event was like we
haven't alone you know walk through and
they made it warrant and they didn't see
him I guess they weren't bugged they
couldn't get tons of people through in a
day yeah um but yeah so I you know I get
the sense that they stuck with it and
they sort of facilitated that and I you
know I mean they're not the same kind of
haunt you know it's not always about
scary I mean these ones I feel like
it'll always be with the only time will
tell you that's like Oh we'll only know
in October but I feel like the October
show will always be the centerpiece the
sort of piece there was this time these
are all like advertisers yeah kind of
and I cuz I cuz again I I know a little
bit about their last cycle it's like the
first thing I went to of theirs was the
main event you know sort of in October
last year that's the one that runs for
the month you know they had a sponsor it
was in an actual you know two or three
story it was an actual building gallery
space downtown um and they were there
for more than you know two or three days
yeah so I feel like that's when they can
really start signing and and you know
putting stuff up and really making a
fixture out of it you know yeah and and
building that show I feel like this
stuff with what they did last year it
seems like they sort of came up with
this sort of a few part story and they
sort of played that out and the show in
october was [ __ ] fantastic but some
of the other stuff was like there was
one like preview event that was more
just sort of an eerie meditation thing
and then we went to the scavenger hunt
which was which was cool if not you know
rough around the edges and a little bit
you know it wasn't as nuts as the actual
experiment was it was still cool
you know all or at least to me it was so
cool um you know requiring of some
patrons you know he's an experiment and
it was sort of thrown together with not
a ton of time to spare and it seems like
this time they've taken that concept of
like let's do a few parts to this
storyline and actually you know plan out
how these events would work um and it
seems like you know it's they're getting
their legs I feel like each year they
get their legs more in a different way I
didn't see the first show but I heard
the first show is more traditional a
little more like you have a flashlight
you're in just sort of the basement of
this old building yeah you don't know
where people are gonna come from the
first one felt more or from what I heard
it it sounds like the first one was more
like a traditional kind of escape room
thing not necessarily an escape room
like like with intense amounts of
puzzles but I don't know there was there
were more blackout comparisons I don't
think it was ever as aggressive as
actively aggressive in its tone oh it's
you know aesthetics as blackout is but
um you know people were like oh yeah
it's kind of like blackout you know
maybe a bit eerie ER but still it's like
all they know your name and they'll do
stuff there was one room I heard about
that I heard was really cool huh where
they took you and they stood you in the
middle of a room for way too long and
dark and then hit the lights and just
tons of people in robes were standing
around you alpha so I that was that was
quick I think I didn't get to see that
show to know but um and then the second
year when they did the all the enola
stuff everyone I know who went to that
show said like this is okay now they've
found what alone is Leia you know they
found this strange surreal almost
Lynchian thing that's not a hundred
percent horror but there is horror and
and some of the darker emotions involved
with it um but this this new cycle the
hole underneath the rainbow like I don't
know it feels like it's it feels like it
keeps on teasing about gearing up to
something that I honestly don't know if
it's going to pan out or not yeah OSIS
I'm
cuz like you know the this new thing at
scare la it's you know it was another
going to the big dark dimly lit with
some colored lights conference room
everybody sits under another kind of
gauzy sort of pearly sheet and these
three actors were telling this is
basically this multi angled story about
a guy a guy in an aquarium watching an
octopus in a tank and a mom nearby
remarking on the guy and so it's like
there was a there was like one actress
that was just giving kind of like a
objective point of view of the scene
there was an actor that was narrating
the internal thoughts of the guy looking
at the octopus of the tank and he
sounded like he was having like a tiny
acid flashback and then there was the
thoughts of my mom just like wondering
where her kid is and just kind of being
a little weirded out by the guy staring
at the octopus and then you know people
were selectively pulled out from under
the sheet with the light shining on them
and then you kind of crawled on your
hands and knees through this this
pitch-black sort of tunnel in the
labyrinthine little tunnel I know that
was go I mean most of yeah second
installment was in total darkness yeah
just logistically is like I don't know
if they've got they must have some kind
of night vision set up because you know
people are maneuvering you in the dark
yeah and and I went crawling under as
you crawling or as you were crawling
through the tunnel or whatever was you
felt hands kind of grasp you here and
there yeah I mean as I was growing to
another body sort of joined sort
intertwined with my outside arm and and
sort of joined with me in that and then
you know started showering me in these
in these like cardboard shaving yeah
whatever was coating the floor yeah um
yeah I mean these these two so far I
mean they're interesting and you know
like these um they're not you know i do
want more you know i do want the rushes
and the stuff that happened in the main
show then I guess more of the individual
I guess that's all that's missing for me
is like that sense of individualized set
Pete's like to me to to walk into a
pitch black room and have the light
suddenly jump on and you're surrounded
by people alone that's interesting to be
coming coming into you know the dance
party room or or you know getting thrown
in a chair is like there were the the
diffusion and the refraction ones felt
different because it wasn't a lot of
one-on-one in a sense yeah I think
that's what I think that's what made the
dance party room I diffusion so I guess
prominent in my memory because it was
the one time with me on the table and
the the dancer on the table like really
really looking into my eyes and just
holding that gaze for a while if Ellie
this is the first time this is the one
time where this haunt is really getting
at me and specifically to me yeah in a
deeper way yeah i'm looking for that too
with these you know like i feel
positively towards them like i like the
stuff that that they're doing but i do
that is what i'm craving from these now
if i really hope and I really hope that
as they build or at least you know when
october hits i really hope that it is
that you know like this is the
experience designed for for you to walk
through alone no no exceptions you know
it's also the scarily one was free yeah
so i owe the scare away one was free
with a with a ticket to the calm yeah so
I always sort of i cut slack for free
events yeah cuz it's because you get the
sense like this was a demo that yeah
they worked it into their their multi
part of thing they're trying to do but
this was also like you know a demo that
the con wanted them to do yeah and so I
get since this was probably not where
most of the resources went yeah and
given that I mean you know I I enjoyed
stripping out to colored lights and just
the general weirdness but yeah I do want
it to
become more I want to feel the hand more
strongly and I do want to be alone more
strongly yeah so you know it's like I I
enjoyed myself on Sunday most definitely
but but yeah he's like I am starting to
crave all the rush that was you know the
enola experience the enola a cycle
because that was and pina like that was
maybe it's just because it was the first
one but it was also like you know you
there right now they're doing a lot with
we have a lot of people and we're sort
of separating you and then putting you
back together and stuff like that
whereas at least the show I went to last
year was we came in five at a time from
the alley from the waiting area of the
alleyway and pretty soon each of us was
abducted and from then on out it was
just us and them you know us and whoever
should be in the next room and and you
know they had two stories or that whole
building was there was a room after room
after room it was like an hour long
experience so like this one I think they
said it was like a 20 minute on Sunday
the one in June was like a half-hour
plus buffer time yeah it was supposed to
like the jewel was supposed to be a half
hour it felt longer yeah I think part of
that is just because of buffer yeah cuz
you know you're sitting in that theater
and art parceling people on yeah whereas
I get the sense again I don't you never
know but I think that's probably since
the first show the first alone you know
it was in October during hunt season
second main shows October during pond
season this one culminates in October
during on season I feel like that when
all the big stuff is going to play out
and you know and we saw the sep tember
12 to see if the September one is going
to be you know a step up or what if
that's going to be a bigger one or if
it's going to be in a more of more on
the scale of the scope of what the june
one was and then we'll see if the
october one is you know bigger than all
of that or what and I sort of feel like
you know since this is still
digi you know June august/september
you're getting closer but still it's
like the people who are going to go do
this at those times of you or have to do
would probably have to be into this kind
of thing more than just oh it's
halloween time like cuz alone isn't a
halloween event or it's not a halloween
specific event like it it would work
theoretically anytime but yeah I imagine
they'll get more traffic and they would
have on a bun you know October on season
proper yeah it's like when black op is a
show I try to imagine what like a
year-round alone park would be like the
love theme park would be a very strange
proposal yeah and it would have a very
slow fee yeah it would be cool there
anytime um I think at some point like it
I want to do some out with some friends
and we kept on joking about the idea of
sad land nothing bar called sad land
just a bunch of more morbid rise yeah
you know it's like down from like I try
to think of like where where this riff
one but we had ideas of like you know
like you know you would have a ride
light down you'd have like a ride words
I can get on a roller coaster and it
drives for a bunch of scenes of
atrocities throughout human history or
there would be like a bunch of costume
characters that were all very sad that
would you know like very depressed
looking costume characters that you can
take photos with and like we had
anything like what would be letters
about sad land is it like as a theme
park was all really great really cool
there's a la production values the rides
were all really well designed and really
fun but all the trappings and all the
design and all the the dressing would
just be super depressing this is a lot
of money spent on some really depressing
yeah this instead of a [ __ ] are you
David oh you get you could have a like a
small yeah just whatever one's self
doing a funeral yeah it's just a funeral
dirge playing as a song just in every
language
yeah that would be just ride on a boat
through and all the music is just the
lock ramosa yeah at a certain point it
all starts to kind of do too because
even though even the band's not really
ya can't keep it up yeah seven yeah
build it bill that they woke up that and
Todd's didn't tossed know the sounds is
Disneyland burned down because game jr.
ran amok yeah no I mean I I am a fan I
feel like you know it's like black guy
doesn't show in February or something or
they've done shows how the site of
haunts the agenda Valentine's show yeah
we're just people aggressively love you
and like give you bear hugs um but
they've done shows outside of haunt
season and those are for blackout fans
blackout as fans and I feel like the
first few parts of the sequence are for
alone fans just like the scavenger hunt
was for a loan fans and I think it's
like for people who are into haunts that
may be a little confusing because I know
some people whose first below thanks for
your first alone experience and like my
friends and who we saw it scare away
yeah not in super scare away he was the
basement food for the escape room free
basement oh I didn't know but I didn't
seem at a scavenger hunt oh yeah so I
mean that being the first experience is
like yeah that's that's not is it
digging of some of the things that are
cool about all on their creative moment
but it's not what it didn't necessarily
buddy all that supposed to [ __ ] season
like this is so great um and I feel like
these ones are like yeah these have some
things that are really cool about this
and it's cool for fans but even he would
mean it's like I enjoyed the first two
billion I'm like all right now let's
kick it into high gear like I want to it
I want to do I want the full thing I
want the rushes of you know it's like
you know exploring fear lonely
this and these strange situations to be
put in you know and also you know they
also got had actors and stuff you know
these people get paid and there are a
lot of room the water actors so I feel
like that's where the most of the sorts
of people go I soon get this inkling
that that that's when the big one is is
Ferguson sweet um so I that's that's
that's sort of my theory right now it's
like all bets are off or the jury will
remain kind of in the corridor until
that one comes no um and they've also
got they have you seen have you read
about intimate know what's intimate they
have a new section on their website oh
that's right I I know that that was
something that I remember reading about
intimate as being like a thing that they
were planning or working on is that open
now or what ah soon I guess they have a
second section other website just
basically explains what it is it's like
its new thing they're going to do it i
think in january um and it's described
it is like a multi-day experience
designed for one person no exception
then basically you have to come in for a
physical interview they will the like
contact interview like family coworkers
will do a background check and they'll
design an experience around you that
will take you to the you know basically
the gist of the paragraph was like
you'll go into the depths of alone miss
wow those things that alone likes to
bring and explore and stuff like that
and you'll descend deep with him to
those um so yeah there that one I was
reading about and I started to get
nervous again I was like that sounds
really intense yeah um my question is
how are they gonna get your family
members to two I guess give them what
they for it here's and yeah I imagine
that there's at least they'll probably
be at least some minor briefing from
either you or or because I
I'm remembering that scene in eternal
sunshine where where the cards are sent
out in me like hey you know your friend
has just recently had this relationship
it expunged from your memory don't
mention it to them ever again I imagine
that'd be really [ __ ] weird to
receive that so imagine imagine like
getting that that message from a lung
thing like yeah your friend signed up
for a lung intimate we're gonna ask you
some personal questions about them and
they totally signed up for this so if
you don't know what a loan is yeah like
imagine that call or coming to you yeah
get really gonna get particularly
weirded out and you would be very
concerned for whoever is purporting to
signed up for this yeah Jesus you good
so I don't know how they're gonna handle
that and right now it basically says you
know if you go to a lot of experience
step on you click on intimate the
letters are upside down and backwards oh
um you know there's the breakdown it's
just a couple paragraphs and then it
basically says more info soon and you
can sign up for the newsletter to get
the info you can Senate and so that
sounds wicked you know it sounds like it
would be fun otsego it might be and they
would have to find some way to schedule
it works like you know you don't want
you don't want to be like in the middle
of work and then suddenly you have to
just means your job to do what save me
some big kidnaps here yeah somebody
kidnaps you or just like you know your
your we're in a place where you're not
your 100% not ready for so it's like oh
my you know you're going on the alone
experience like this is freaking me out
and also I have an actual life I'm
supposed to be managing back home yeah
I'm pretty sure that whatever the day is
that you're gonna I got imagine the
whatever the experience did I around you
is so scheduled for Arbor Day yeah
everybody gets that Dale yeah hey I got
imagine whatever the actual whatever
your go time is whenever you're going to
walk into whatever experience has been
cobbled out of this information I'm sure
they'll coordinated day with you somehow
it's especially you know I don't know
how limited it's gonna be and I don't
know what it's gonna cost but it seems
like for that experience if it's
tailored to you they'll also they'll
find a way to make sure that you can do
it you know yeah I mean not in the same
way but you know the scavenger hunt was
like it's this day if you want to come
have this day free yeah so um ya know
that I mean that sounds cool and I'm
just like I i like them general i always
feel good natured about them just
because you know it's creative and it's
a different side of this you know it's
like i do share someone like yeah i do
want this to pick up and i hope you know
to be loud um by the actor because
that's the thing is like I want to be
fully immersed and like these first two
have been intermittently emerged um but
you know the big show was fully like i
was i was there i was just in my body in
those rooms you know and there was also
no expectation that i was very nervous
you know it was my first time ever doing
one so um yeah i mean i feel like the
real test especially you know perhaps
for you or for anybody gonna prove who's
yet to see you know the amazing Michelle
I feel like the real test will come when
the October failover no I'm it's coming
that makes the most sense and I knew I
liked their concepts and stuff like that
it's been a very low five um thus far
yeah they've been doing a lot of which
are simple things like you know like the
sheet over your head without the pulse
and colored biting faces interesting and
it's I don't know I I mean they sustain
those elements for those moments for so
long it's like you can't it those
moments were just the sheet over your
head in the end of flashing light that
only really worked for me in the June
show because it's like I felt like I was
alone I felt like I was specifically put
in that room with the sheet over me
alone there was all this like noise rock
going on to really make it feel hypnotic
and after a while I and I was there to
bake long enough for me to really feel
like I was thinking kind of like
to a transfer us this last one where
there was an element like you know the
group bid with the shooting the colored
lights was a group fit in there were you
know there was an octopus story being
read out where it was you know it felt
like a different animal entirely in
interviewing vet saying um I guess sense
of trance or sense of hypnosis going on
yeah and there's a part where they they
shove you you know you you've crawled
through the maze and then somebody puts
you against the wall with another cheat
over your head and they make you fold
the light flashing in your face with the
sheet over you oh you didn't do them no
I think that there's their subtle tweaks
and differences I think we touched on
that and the dream chair to it I think
certain details change here and there
damn where you are what's going on
elsewhere because I was never made to
hold a light shining in my face yeah I
was I was I was putting in support with
another sheet over my head up and they
have a little tiny light colored stroke
that I was supposed to hold towards me
and I was just sort of you know pressed
up against the wall for really good and
I felt open because I just seen actually
Erica I just seen Erica like get quote
for the process of that room then moved
on from the door so it just like I know
I just felt like I miss this oddly
different thing yeah so I guess it's
just a matter of having to stay tuned
yeah eyes I icing but that's well on on
the topic of staying tuned is there
anything coming months that you're
excited for oh man um all rights it's
getting to be hot season and that's it
you know it's big part of my life so I'm
getting excited for that I mean that's
that's what I in general life that's
sort of what I'm working on right now is
finding things to be excited for yeah um
also just because you know it's hard to
get excited for stuff because you know
things let you down
yeah true detective what a lot of
comedians yeah I am tentatively excited
for the goose bumps River just because I
grew up reading and loving those yeah I
I don't know i'm curious i didn't see
the trailer I can understand imagine it
being fun and campy yeah Jack Black at
the helm but it's also like I mean I
remember as a kid the Goosebumps books
really do like freaked me out yeah then
we're kind of engrossing so I don't know
what like having them be camping but if
having the goosebumps believe you can't
be with an RL stine character is more
like for the nostalgic fans and less you
know for kids today works like you know
we're making a really good you know I
feel like the project is more geared
towards getting people who are nostalgic
for goose bumps and less about like hey
you know there's a whole new generation
of kids and we're going to make for them
up you know a horror movie for kids to
enjoy yeah and I do yeah I wish Poulter
get suited had it succeeded at that um
yeah I get that concern and I've seen
the trailer and I mean off the bat it
yeah it's like I don't know how scary or
not it would be or if it'll just be more
of an adventure but it does look a bit
more a little less goofy than the show
was cuz i really like the show is good
but the show is you know stiff and and
you know there's some cool effects here
and there but you know this shows could
be a sort of stiff and wide I um and
this you know it tickles me for
different reasons but I might be that
you know I am that sort of like how I
remember I used to one who's fun time
like you know so it's worked for me so
far getting my interest partly to uh I
mean I love jack black anyway but also
just like the way he seems to be playing
RL stine tickles me so cuz he almost
looks like a weird Truman Capote good
you know just who
happens to now be reclusive and its
author be great many you know spooky
books about 12 year old I wonder I
wonder what the other meal RL stine
feelings about this he's CMC ordered by
RL stine yeah yeah IRA well done yeah I
think he's everything he said about it
has been you know reasonably positive
Jack Black which just like um sometimes
exactly I would visit the set I big use
me I'm get very upset we've talked about
a good amount of times and you know him
I know he's at least seen a few cuts of
it ya know it seems positive i don't
know you could never tell I guess with
those things but I guess he wouldn't
have to talk as many times as he has
also I mean just the premise kind of
reminds me of one of the stories anyway
it's kind of like the typewriter one
where the kid everything he writes comes
to life oh you know cuz in that at least
in the premise for the murder Brazil are
you a friend of the dark episode that
was similar to that of enough i think i
remember this this to me because some of
those some of those were legit creepy
and I you know when you have like a
twelve-year-old doing all this stuff
like there is a tendency for them to get
a little like well like a little campy
yeah in that way but there were some
that were like legit creepy on are you
afraid dark yeah I do remember that and
that was something that was interesting
to me it's like you know there would he
can't we be are you afraid of the dark
episodes that were less scary than
others but it's like it felt like with
are you afraid of the dark the camping
this was a bug and not necessarily a
feature yeah yeah the camping this was
coming from it being like you know a you
know a low-budget Canadian show with a
bunch of you know kid actors that you
know we're very green that's why are you
afraid of the dark had the camping as
far as the point of are you the friend
dark was to actually be a horror show
for kids yeah and so you met a little
still was scary at times yeah you had
that danger so because if you're if
you're intentionally can't be everything
is safe you know huh and I don't know
how how the goosebumps will turn up in
that life or not
what the premise I thought was neat
because it's all about you know it's
like that this this kid you know moves
into you know his they're always moving
Goosebumps books like they move into a
new house and just so have this
reclusive writer lives next door with
his daughter and you know they go in the
house one day and they final his
manuscripts or whatever and they like
open one and you know one of the
monsters escapes or something that and
it kind of reminded me of that was a
monster yeah probably dead house um but
yeah so like and it reminded me of that
typewriter episode that they did on the
show yeah and I think was a book as well
so I don't know I'm tentatively excited
for that there's good I'm kind of just
excited to continue I just discovered a
couple things you know I like I said I
just started watching Marin and checking
out his comedy and I'm really liking
that vibe um ask some early Marc Maron
copy that that long though but from his
19 stuff that was just like auto rebut
on HBO he looks so you see Victoria yeah
and and things Marc Maron is one of the
lucky few people who like that dude was
like born to be 50 because he's 50 looks
so [ __ ] good like he's got the salt
and pepper he's got the glasses you know
the the sort of the van dyke and he's
making it work and he's also cleaned up
you know I and and the show it comes
over into his comedy joseph louis
letters was like his 90s sand a bit he
was joking about antidepressants and he
was just like by the friend I was like
she she said that she was on
antidepressants I was like what is that
in eight basically at one point he says
you were taking a drug that doesn't get
you high man what is what what is that
that's what he was just like acting
coach initially incredulous about the
concept of taking a drug but not to get
hot yes and I was like oh yeah you know
what a problem didn't you a lot of
problems in and I mean that's that's
what I found very cool about his show
and I haven't heard all of his stand ups
but I heard stinky pain I was in the
most recent one
just thinking about stand-up comedy
that's the vibe I've gravitated toward
as I've grown older is like I like the
comics who get up on stage will sort of
just kind of talk and it's not
necessarily jokes it's just know kind of
observations about life and injecting
humor into that and it's like I really
like a lot of Louie CK stuff but Lucy
can't has a bit more of an aggressive
energy whereas some of the more recent
Marc Maron and it bleeds over into the
to the show too is like it's kind of a
guy's sorting out his problems and kind
of acknowledging some of his
misanthropic tendencies but in a way
that's not it's like on the show you
know it's like eat it's not always
flattering to hammer to any number of
characters and that's used for humor but
also you know it seems like he's really
working through some of these issues in
earnest and there's a certain level of
earnestness and a sort of you know
honestly honestly that comes with that
where it's not as it's not quite as in
your face and it's not quite as
aggressive and I kind of like that like
it it makes it kind of close to the
ground it's like it's not being like
yeah I'm [ __ ] up but that's cool it's
like yeah I'm [ __ ] up and I'm trying
not to be [ __ ] up and it can be funny
but it's still [ __ ] up and I'm trying
to get better you know yeah and and I
think he's made a nice little show out
of that as it and you know the comedy to
you know reflects that no um see I've
been I've been vibing on that Avery um
I'm gonna have to check that how it
feels like yeah well I means it's not
crazy in your face you know buds and it
gets in it gets better every time keep
its rhythm but you know i'm joined
they're bite-sized i found i quite
enjoyed these you know 22-minute a
22-minute shows a lot easier to watch
over the course of the day especially if
you just need to kind of chill out for a
second you know it's like okay I can
hang off the mark for 20 minutes and see
what what you know see what he's up to
what high jinks ensue you know before
you know going back to what everything
or you know the wet hot game yeah the
wet hot getting the wet yeah or what hot
getting sound
it's like a really gross 90s hip-hop
true it didn't last very long so wet I
game now I'm just think of the Sugar
Hill Gang oh yeah I never really liked
their version patty I got to tell you
everybody goes like oh yeah tonto jump
on it and I'm like no yes not there's a
reason I don't like that really yeah I
feel like that's something that is
better is just the instrumental without
the call-and-response stuff going on but
yeah foo detective true detective I
can't think I can't talk about true
detective without thinking of the of the
the father John misty song true
affection yeah like they're the phonemes
are too similar to get stuck in my head
detective hey it seems like a lot of
those guys that show need to have a
crazy conversation yeah and and father
Jon Missy was on a an original song that
closed out the first season it turns out
like the last episode just was over the
credit ok I think it was over the
credits of the last episode specifically
home that's good he does a great there's
a great video of him online just mixing
a drink and scat singing oh I would have
to say this for some kind of its for
some kind of liquor but like I'm really
excited cuz I'm going to see father John
misty in October lucky duckling yeah so
here's hoping here's hoping for good
show apparently he's really fun live
from everything I've seen it seems like
he's a showman yeah I heard I heard a
story of someone i think it was like a
coachella music festival someone threw
like one of those like right long Pony
stakes that a unicorn head on it in his
face and in between songs he like took
it from the audience and made out with
made out with the fake unicorn head and
then threw back in the audience who made
a call me sign and then like a few weeks
or a few months later he tweeted that
[ __ ] unicorn still hasn't called
at I think I've seen footage of this
show or something yeah this sounds very
familiar he's a cookie cat man like he
seems like one of those dudes who's like
very real but you either get along with
him or you don't um he seems like he's
got that bit of that like now wildfire
yeah and his shirt like every
performance I've ever seen at least
recorded you know seems like he would be
great to watch live and he seems like
he's got a lot of energy a lot of
presents yeah he's kind of like it's
kind of half in between the music's he
does do some genuine like basically
interstitial comedy oh yeah she was very
animated yeah and I mean even during the
more serious songs he still brings a
sort of you know sardonic boisterousness
if there was a word to describe father
John Missy's like character endings just
music and and his sort off stage persona
it would be a good word and I would like
to use that word if I could ride rise
the word right yeah like a like a bread
their deli exactly like that man bread
when he's got that like Maine and the
big old beard and yeah he's just always
him man no he's father John misty he's
very good at like portraying a guy that
just kind of I don't want to say tired
but just kind of like a kind of like a
an arch sort of you know almost like
existential is kind of like yeah world's
pretty [ __ ] up that's kind of funny
and I'm just gonna go you know do
whatever I want yeah it is it me exactly
yeah that is kind of the nutshell
persona of f JM ya for Jim fujian you
saw a wall nation recently I did I did I
went I got my passport and took a trip
to the AWOLNATION and you're now a
foreign national I am allowed to bring
fruits and another kind
without being stopped and questioned I
was how was the nation's oh it's great i
mean they put on a terrific show they're
coming back i think in october on for
like the the 2 point 0 leg of the tour
but um well yeah I mean they're their
energy is fantastic and like I mean
their stage show is pretty simple like
it's you know they have their big and
backdrop and they have a lot of lights
and stuff and I got a is all most
interesting because they had a lot of
fog effects and a lot of lights and it
almost forced you to put your camera
away because we were only gonna get
silhouettes like you could see but the
cameras get silhouette yeah it was like
everyone was really responsive it's a
very responsive crowd i gotta say like
they can engage a crowd that's in a way
that's hard to do here um so yeah I mean
the setlist is good there was you know
some oldies some new stuff you know he's
pretty great put on a really good show
and they sounded good you know and and
you know because of the nature of the
music you know to transitioning from the
records to live like there is a definite
difference you know it's more robust in
the live setting there there are more
guitars and there's more you know it's a
little heavier and a little higher
energy you know at at to show huh so G
ass was a G a show that's to borrow a
phrase I haven't used in 10 years he g
GS GS g it was a gas show it was a gas
jumpin Jack frass it's a GS GS
especially as all mountain goats back in
May how were they it was cool it was
that the Mayan so was in that it was it
felt nice and kind of intimate in a
sense yeah there were a lot of people
that were just doing standing room but
you know we we were up in the up in the
block seats in the balcony and yeah you
did cuz it is a smaller venue and it
wasn't super packed it just felt it had
that right balance of like feeling like
you were you were kind of connected to
to john darnell because you know his
music his musical stylings are very
personal hmm and he is the kind of guy
that wouldn't he's the kind of guy that
would not fill in arena yeah yeah not
necessarily like he couldn't draw a
crowd that big but just because you know
you if you're listening to UM if you're
listening to a you know a mountain goats
track you feel like you're it's kind of
getting at your heart and a very kind of
down-to-earth way mm-hm like him I would
contrast him with um neutral milk hotel
because we saw a neutral milk hotel at
the Hollywood Bowl and because the you
know neutral milk hotel can get more mom
Bostic or can get more poetic and isn't
as as grounded in a sense because John
toenails lyrics are very poetic in their
own right whether it's a grounded kind
of poetry whereas neutral milk hotel
gets more expansive and gets more more
stretched out and spread out so I you
know neutral milk hotel can do the
Hollywood Bowl and john darnell can do
the Mayan and both of them can play to
those venues in that kind of setting
really well to give a to give a very
cool fun live performance so would you
say that neutral milk hotel packed the
Hollywood Bowl you know I it looked like
a big crowd the place didn't look
actually pretty full de Casta says when
to make a joke huh it's good I you know
I was just at the mine but not really oh
that's right next door the mind and
because I was curious when you start a
sentence with allies just there but not
really I was just like are you [ __ ]
lying to me like now is like I was I
went to see shakey graves and I velasco
and which is right by which is right
literally next door um is the next
building and I've sorted the Velasco is
the subway is it ruin I don't I could've
eaten fresh all you could have I'm so
sorry you have gotten that good yoga mat
bread yoga
bread and a yoga mat child porn bust
bread dude that is like not that I had a
lot of faith in them I never really
thought about Jared Fogle in any way
except for like oh yeah he's that guy
who's vaguely good-natured from subway
who lost weight yeah I did it but I like
you say nothing nothing is sacred not
nothing is not even the sandwich man now
as other nothing to say not even our
sandwich man our sacred like everything
is a letdown at some point it seems like
it's like even you dude but even you
let's get let's get real Jared Fogle had
the look of the dude that would be
dancing with his daughter at a purity
ball did that happen I'm no cuz I don't
think Jared Fogle has kids but he has
the look of one of those guys yeah I
guess I'm just under every stone is
something terrible and I guess that's
that's what we're learning is the
information age grows more expansive is
that my [ __ ] up but some people man
Jared dude Jerry like some of those
stipulations are horrifying yeah anyway
dank goes dark Oh goes yeah after dark
no yeah so shaky grazed the Velasco and
he puts on a fantastic show he was
supposed to be at the music box at the
fonda what shakey graves is one man
she's got a band shakey graves is a guy
who's who is the shakey graves yeah and
it's actually very amusing to hear him
tell the story there are a few different
like videos and interviews where he
tells the story on his name is alejandra
rose garcia but he goes by shakey graves
and i guess it was just because like
hands and friends were on like a camping
trip you know he's from Texas he's from
like Austin's like that I guess they
were all camping out in this homeless
guy wandered up um and you know like
they were just you know kind of hanging
out and he was like oh you know you
gotta try he had this like bottle
something's like oh you gotta try by
whiskey's like it's really good and so
like they kind of humored him and like
pretended and he's sort of like wandered
off and said something about spooky
wagons
and so they're like spooky wagons like
that sounds like a like a like a you
know like a blues man's name so they all
later on that night gave each other like
old blues man names so there was like I
can't remember what he said the other
ones were but there was like spooky
wagons and like rusty doors or something
like that and then like the one dudes
little brother who's asleep in the tent
got to be droopy wieners and and he got
shakey graves and he was like he pulled
out the guitar you know the next day you
know somewhere a little more public and
was just noodling around there like yeah
like it's great like what are you called
and he just sort of spat out shakey
graves and it's stuck and the people
were he said like people walking by me
what's up shaky like little music that's
really interesting see I just came out
of this like camping trip and then you
know kind of riffing off this kind of
crazy homeless dude and see a shakey
graves is one guy and and a lot of the
videos you'll see online which are great
like his he's one of those dudes who
just when he's playing you really get
the sense that he's just the vessel for
the music like you know there's just
he's locked in and he's doing this
finger picking while singing with the
utmost soul and you know doing a
suitcase drum like it's all over um the
place um not all over the place but you
know he's doing lots of things at once
and just it's all walked together but
during his live show at the belasco on
he did a good job kind of oscillating
because he has a drummer right now he's
a guy called boo um who is his drummer
shakey graves and boo yeah exactly uh
it's kind of cute that way and so like
you know he departs the show just
himself with him and just a suitcase
room then he had boot come out and then
he also had Pat O'Connor come out for
some of the songs so it went from being
a solo to a two piece to a three piece
and it kind of went between those a few
times which was really cool and they
were all you know where they needed to
be and it was all like really cool and
specially sounded greatness that was
great and you know there are always some
songs that aren't recorded you know he's
got a lot of songs that are you know
kind of just live songs so next time
he's in town we should go because he's
[ __ ] fantastic he's and I and I love
his muse
like he's got a really he kind of does
anything dusty as sort of how I
described because it's not it's like
some of it's sort of bluesy some of its
um you know rock and roll's or garage
east of some of it is you know almost
country or bluegrass inspired um you
know it just generally sounds of dust
yeah it sounds a dust you know I guess
they call that Americana or what
everybody and you know it just sounds
real natural you know he's got that Sol
sold bluesman cool so shaky was a his
things man was was be a i love i love
Cornel West because he will describe
people as you'll just describe people as
blues man but of different things just
like a blues man of making pancakes well
like for instance i think this i
actually if i'm remembering correctly
Cornel West he was not he was not deemed
this by himself he was called this
because you know he had a friendship
with BB King and BB King labeled him as
such a BB King labeled him a blues man
of the mind that's awesome yeah I know
right I would love to be a blues man of
mine shouts out again to Cornell west
who is in jail in Ferguson what he went
he went to Ferguson for the the March
for the anniversary of the killing of
Mike Brown and he got arrested Wow is it
already the anniversary yeah good golly
Miss Molly I know great balls of fire
great balls of Billy Squier this um yeah
who shakey graves supposed to play but
it's police box Cornel West he going to
prison is the thing he does this year I
mean less freedom yeah I'm probably good
joke I mean that's going to jail is some
is like a going to jail for cornelis is
collateral damage of him doing [ __ ] all
right it's just like well I'm gonna go
do [ __ ] to call out the horrible
hypocrisy of our culture probably gonna
go to jail but whatever him man is on
the cut net
Ricardo Weston who was just a 17 year
old girl it's like I'm gonna go protest
the police sta probably go to prison
whatever i'll call you like when i get
out here be BRB BRB going to jail BRB in
just like a little prison man emoji this
is like a text to moms like honey where
are you uh protesting the horrible
hippocrates of the American police tape
going to jail BRB pissed emoji cop emoji
jail emoji thumbs up and then 100 yeah
you just love that 100 to follow that
100 i love that skull you do dude my
favorite emoji slide my favorite emojis
that are not based mochis I feel like
this should be a segment of the show is
just like Aaron's favorite emojis
everyone's about the poop emoji now I'm
into the skull the 100 and all little
bees emojis I feel like you should do it
in an emoji segment every show where you
just explain which one's your favorite
and give some kind of reason and half
the time it'll just be the skull yeah or
I have the time it'll be the 100 but
sometimes it might be different I like
the trademark emoji cuz that's that's
useful sometimes for trademarking stuff
yeah I like trading marks I should get I
should do more with the bowl of rice
emoji did what what what um symbolize
rice yeah but I mean how much more can
you do with that you gotta you would
have to eat a lot of rice based cuisine
no I just have to need I would just have
to like symbolize rice frequently this
is symbolic of rice what I find
interesting are like it if of the
concept there's like that that weird
ghost emoji with the tongue sticking out
and then there's like this is a friend
that goes the friendliest ghost you know
and then there's like an Oni mask or
like a kabuki mask a mochi and I'm just
thinking how often do you need to refer
to kabuki theatre frequently I need to
symbolize rice way more often than I
need to refer directly to kabuki theatre
50 theater I do appreciate there are two
different wails of baleen whale and
something that vaguely looks like a
sperm oil yeah you know just in case you
I don't know how they chose these um at
least hear no evil see no evil speak no
evil has a theme and monkey but yeah the
rest days I'm like ah well he's got to
be the ones that y'all chose whatever it
works ah get tired it's a long day yeah
yeah those are our mo geez thanks for
listening to the emoji Alan be emojis
own the emoji this is um this is like
beta testing round two yeah figuring out
what to do so we thank you for joining
us on this grab bag up so grab bag grab
swag from the grab bag yeah I think what
I think that's a good pot of stuff we
talked about some alone Inge we talked
about some TBH yeah you know stuff went
down went all around jump up and down
and move it all right you can sit soon
put your hands in the girls so once
again i am aaron i am Jerry and we're
we're we're we're dang or dank and you
should be dank to you should be dank all
the time yeah everyone should be doing
everyone should just just constantly
have a layer of moisture on their body
yeah just stand under one of those like
tents with the misters yeah like a theme
parks and sand events in the park that
mean it's it's been hot it has been huh
it's been hot but it has not been hot in
Antelope Valley there were which is
bizarre because the place looks so damn
desert II but being up there this past
weekend it's August and it as soon as
the Sun went down it would just become
freezing and windy a goosed adduced a
ghost a ghost maybe that's where the
name for August came from it's the ghost
ones yeah it's the month of ghosts some
time what is was a repair its rise from
the grave this was originally going to
be the month of Halloween but then they
had to change things because
the depression des [ __ ] up yeah
actually no I like October for me yeah
October's a good time for Halloween yeah
it's pumpkin time I jack the pumpkin
king please now all very weird the sound
the screen Jack by the way is going to
be towed around by drones at Disneyland
apparently what yeah Disneyland probably
carry I know disney now Disneyland now
has drones to operate marionettes in
from the sky so I don't know how I feel
about drones and popular secession
wheels drones drones were going to come
to Disneyland eventually like
Disneyland's bread and butter has been
like they're being very creepy and
surveillance II and invasive that's been
dis loves them to surveillance land
exactly by Gottesman Disneyland since de
uno so let's just of course drums we're
gonna go out switching languages on a
dime you're crazy man well I'm sorry man
it's just you know my you know just
that's just me dealing with the give
often highs well done yeah blends I'm
gonna get out my German dictionary right
now and try just just gonna try I don't
know what I'm gonna try but I'm just
gonna try this try hard and cry hard
look that would be the best I heard
sequel Jeff if we cry hard and it would
just be it would just be a retrospective
episode after John McClane's funeral
where John know is it's right before
John McClane's death where I realized
that lately he's been a dick yeah it's
like wow I [ __ ] up most of Russia and
just gave not nary a [ __ ] about it
please it's just him trying to patch
things up with his family without
violence and yet again everyone's like
we want to be called Janeiro we're not
McLain's like this has been the plot for
so long just people not wanting to be
McLain's and he's not even mcclain
anymore he's just grumpy Bruce Willis
yeah what are you talking about Bruce
Willis oh that's right bending that was
my favorite Gary Oldman line oh yeah
dude when he said that in Dracula you're
a wizard Olaf uh said Ultron um has like
[ __ ] off' eyeing a meme I just love
those those those memes that are just
pureed out of a bunch of different memes
yeah what's I always that always took
them any iteration of that where it's
just like a picture of like Sir Patrick
Stewart this is like you're a wizard
Frodo and then a critic credits that to
like Gandalf or something yeah good [ __ ]
Darth Vader I don't know anyhow Benny
thanks for joining us thank you so wait
you're joining us as we probe and figure
[ __ ] huge as the Canadians might say and
thank you for leaving us yeah coming as
you are as you were as I want you to be
as and now you know accepting that the
end is near hmm for now for now but the
end will always begin again in the
beginning next time on lost on laws was
it good entering those numbers and
hitting enter mr. Eko what's a good I
man and I am jarrell and remember kids
chair stay any dang thang mank been my
tanks sticker stick steep at jankowitz